it was pretty crazy i got a chance to
talk to warren buffett on the phone
um some some guy i was talking to i was
saying you know i'm trying to figure out
philanthropy and how to give money away
and literally he goes oh you should talk
to warren buffett
and i was like what do you mean and then
he just like cc introed me to warren
buffett right it was
one of the weirdest things that's ever
happened to me and it was amazing and i
was like kind of nervous like warren
buffett's like my hero
uh you know i i was never not expecting
this it was just like a random
friday and warren buffett's secretary
emails me back and just says oh yeah
you know call call him whenever you know
he'll he'll pick up
and so i call and they get i get put
right through
and it's just warren freaking buffett on
the phone and basically he said you know
oh yeah
i'm not doing anything i can talk for as
long as you want and i just got to pick
his brain
for an hour uh and it was insanely
inspiring
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like my days off on
the road let's travel never looking back
all right
uh shawn is out with his new baby i
asked andrew to come on and do this and
i wanted to do a special segment today
called
billy of the week we actually used to do
these at the end of some episodes but
people liked it and i want to do them
more often i asked andrew
to come on we have two people who were
ready to discuss
and andrew uh andrew doesn't know the
format the way that here's what i wanted
to do i'll go first because i think i
did more research than you
but it looks like you actually did a
fair bit um i'll go first
i'm going to tell you who i'm talking
about and i'm going to explain to you
why they're interesting and then maybe
and i and i picked this person
on purpose maybe you can tell me
who or like what other opportunities are
in this space
or uh and i kind of pick someone similar
to you but
the guy is probably twice your age so uh
he's further along his journey
um but i think it's interesting to you
but we can also talk about
anything else we want to talk about as
we go yeah sounds awesome
um also what's going on how are you uh
you enjoying being the ceo or the
founder of a publicly traded company
yeah yeah it's interesting it's kind of
like um
you know when you start your company
it's really exhilarating um
you know you have your first employees
you start dealing with problems
and you've never done it before and so
your stress level is like 10 out of 10
when you're first doing it you're like i
don't know what matters i don't know
what best practices are
if i have a problem with an employee how
do i deal with it all that kind of stuff
it's that same learning curve so it's
like incredibly exhilarating and
exciting
having a public company it's like a huge
milestone but at the same time i'm like
i'm like a new entrepreneur like i don't
know
what actually matters who to listen to
where to focus
sometimes and that's just you know you
do anything new and it's stressful
so it's been stressful uh for sure but
now i feel like we're on the other side
of it we're starting to feel
uh figure it out and uh it's been really
good is your stop
i ha i check your stuff once a week um
is it up
this week or down or do not even look i
think it's it's kind of coasting i try
not to look at it
yeah it's kind of jumping between about
650 million and a billion dollars
depending on the week
wow um and our podcast has been growing
a ton
and people have criticized me for not
doing introductions so first of all i'm
sam parr
i co-host this with sean perry who is
now
way more famous than i am because he's
crushing it on content um
but i started this thing called the
hustle just sold it for mid-eight
figures to
uh hubspot and then andrew is a friend
of sean and eyes
uh andrew i'll do a quick introduction
for you and then you could say but
andrew
started this thing called metal lab
which is a an agency that makes all
types of amazing stuff and using the
products
or using the profit from his agency he
went and bought a ton of companies
and invested in a ton of stuff now his
whole enterprise does like 100 million
ish in revenue
very profitable and he just did a spec
and took one of his uh
uh pixel union one of uh we commerce he
took one of his companies that makes
shopify
plugins and took it public and it's now
at a six
five hundred six hundred seven hundred
million dollar market cap did i miss
anything there
yeah i mean i i kind of uh i always
think like i'm a designer who ended up
becoming an investor just like how sam's
a writer who ended up becoming an
entrepreneur
um it's been a process of just kind of
stumbling into stuff and
a lot of why we've gotten as big as we
have is because i just
i don't like doing stuff that i don't
like doing and so i just kept
delegating the stuff i didn't enjoy and
when you do that a lot
uh in its kind of final form that's just
investing where you're hiring ceos to
run your companies and incentivizing
them
um yeah it's it's crazy i never would
have thought we would get to the size
we're at now and it's been
it's been a cool ride and the reason i'm
asking this next question it's
because it's related to the first story
i want to get to but how many companies
does
uh how many let's say how many companies
do you guys own
or partly own and then how many have you
invested in and own like a like a
like a smallish check size so we control
um as in like we have over you know 50
in i think 35 businesses and then we
have another
probably 40 to 50 um minority
investments so those would be anything
from like little hundred thousand dollar
venture bets to minority prep equity
where we might own
10 or 15 of a business so in the
100 range-ish total deals yeah something
like that
so the guy i'm going to talk about today
his name is brad jacobs bradley jacobs i
think he goes by but
we're gonna call him brad jacobs and
this person is super interesting because
they have started
uh five companies that have either gone
public
or are worth over a billion dollars he
started age 23 he's 64 now
uh google them brad jacobs he's worth
somewhere in the range of three four
five billion dollars
and he's bought or in both he doesn't
like invest passively like a venture
check
they buy companies and he's bought
something like
six 700 companies and he's done it
across a variety of industries and he's
done the same strategy
over and over and over again in
different industries and it's incredibly
interesting and this guy
uh is very fascinating to me for a
variety of reasons that i'm going to
explain
but andrew have you heard of this guy
brad jacobs do you know anything about
this never i don't know anything
that's kind of why he's cool he's kind
of on the under the radar if you google
him he's uh
he's got like a bald head and he looks
like a finance guy
because he wears a tie and he's like
pretty um
well spoken and you think that he's just
like a private equity person and i guess
maybe he is
but he's really an entrepreneur he's
very entrepreneurial and he's uh
far more interesting than just a lot of
the typical new york
hedge funny type of folks and so i'm
gonna give you a quick story about his
background
so he started five things that have been
quite meaningfully sized so the first
was uh it was called amorex
oil associates he started it when he was
and it was an oil biz it was basically
like an oil brokerage firm
which uh i'm not entirely sure what that
entails
but i imagine it just means connecting
folks who created the oil to large
businesses who are buying the oil
and within a very short amount of time
only about four years
uh remember he started this when he was
23 so by the age of 27
amorex his oil business was doing 4.7
billion
dollars in gross gross oil bookings
meaning he would that's how much oil
they're buying and uh and selling
now i imagine his company kept a tiny
percent of that like one or two or three
percent
but incredibly impressive for a young
guy and after a few years he sells that
business for
a billion dollars then only a couple
months after that
he starts this thing called hamilton
resource uh
hamilton resource he starts out of uh uh
england
he convinces a french bank to give him a
billion dollars line of credit which
he was quite successful already even
though he was crazy young
but uh he made it happen and he went and
secured a line of credit
and here's what he said he goes we moved
physical cargos of oil from one place to
another
the 80s turned out to be a great time in
the oil business and i built hamilton
up to about a billion dollars in
revenues and did business in dozens of
countries
uh dozens of countries before i moved
back to the states in 1989.
so between 83 and 89 he started this
business
and it also was huge i believe he ended
up selling it for
a billion dollar north of a billion
dollars so that's business number two
business number three a little bit of a
of an odd one was waste
management um i don't think there's
anyone out there doing waste management
stuff now that's brand new but there's a
ton of companies that
at the time started in the 70s 80s and
90s like waste management the company
waste management
and what they did was they would go out
and find tons of mom and pop
waste management companies because back
then that's how it was it probably is a
little bit to this day
but he started this thing called united
waste management which eventually
became the fifth largest solid waste
business in america
and it had a very very very simple
business plan which was
buy landfills and small markets by many
of the local trucking companies that
were serving those markets
optimize the truck routes maximize the
pricings get margins up
achieve size so that they have the
capability to scale
and they did that and the strategy
worked really well and in just
five years our earnings compounded
annually annually by 55
and the and he took the company public
something like
eight months after starting it and the
stock price went up as well 50
every single year for like five years
eventually
that company grew to 3.9 billion dollars
in revenue
and 1.2 billion dollars in ebitda with
750 locations and 13 000 employees is
this
freaking crazy oh sorry that i just gave
you the numbers i gave you the numbers
for um
his next business but the waste
management grew to 2.5 billion dollars
in revenue
oh sorry uh 2.5 billion dollars and an
exit to waste management
nuts right that's crazy so i i one of
the most interesting things about this
is like
i always think there's like um four
different types of entrepreneurs right
there's the innovators so
let's just take let's take um chipotle
as an example right so there's the
innovator there's the guy who rolled the
first burrito
i was like oh [__] this tastes really
good then there's the remixer there's
the person who creates chipotle they
take the burrito they package it up they
create a brand around it
then there's the scalers the person who
scales chipotle to a hundred locations
and then there's the optimizer the
person who just sits on top makes sure
it doesn't blow up
and gets as much as possible gets as
much juice out of the lemon as they can
and this guy's a great example of a
scaler
someone who just takes something that
already works that's already proven
and just does a much better job of it
and rolls it out makes it scalable
and builds something massive and it's
super it's super interesting
um because i'd say i i kind of fall into
this camp
um at the same time i feel like what's
sexy about this guy is actually how
boring the businesses are
right they're they're so basic these are
things that are like undisruptible and
when you build them it's like 100-year
business or something which i think is
really cool
whereas what we do is like five you got
to think in five year
uh chunks i completely agree and if you
scroll up to this document that we have
open and you click source
um the source that i'm using for a lot
of this and this is so
interesting um so we're on business
number three i'll get to four and five
in a second
but when what this guy does and then
when i wrap up all five i'll explain to
you
what my lessons uh learn from this guy
are but i'll say one of them right now
which is what this guy does is he raises
money like a madman
and it's not like a ridiculous amount i
mean
saying you're raising tens of millions
of dollars i guess for the for the
average show
yeah that is a ridiculous amount but
he's got a track record and he turns
them into multi-billion dollar things
but uh so kind of tens of millions of
dollars is not that much money
um but if you click that source thing
what
what does that take you to to the sec
okay i found this file on the scc and i
don't really know what this is
but i don't even remember how i came
across it but this is what interested me
it's a q a session of him having written
it out
and he basically lays out the strategy
of his fourth and fifth business
and so what this appears to be is a q a
that he prepared and they showed this to
a ton of potential investors
a ton of potential banks and they decide
to invest in him
and i think this was before the company
even started
is that what that is so you're saying
this is what he raised on
like there's no deck there's nothing
it's just this is the thing he goes out
and he says
read this document and you can invest
i'm not entirely sure but i think that
is part of it i
it's called this is called a schedule
14a which
i i'm not an expert in the sec i believe
that is something that you have to
answer before a board of directors
at a publicly traded company um
raises money but i'm not entirely sure
but it's interesting though because he
writes in wonderful
straightforward simple english and you
could read his entire strategy which i'm
going to go through in a second
um but skim that while i bring well i
i'll summarize the next two businesses
that he did so he started
um i told you he started two oil things
but base those were oil brokerage
businesses
then he started um well waste management
business now his fourth one is called
united rentals
now i don't know if you see this in
canada but if you pay attention to this
now and if you're listening
to this and you live in america go on a
drive in downtown
the downtown city wherever you live and
look at the big box trucks
and look at the rental equipment so look
at um like the caterpillars or the
bobcats or the the um the construction
equipment
as well as the um portal potties
and anything involving construction or
trucking go and look at those things and
i guarantee you
on a lot of them you're gonna see united
rentals well that
is the fourth company that he started
and he started it with the idea of
the same thing of voice management he
wanted to go out and he wanted to find
a massive industry that was highly
segmented
by small businesses where that were
profitable and great but they didn't
have enough capital to grow
and they were kind of bad at sales and
that's what he did and so he founded it
and in just
five years five years it grew to
four billion in revenue and 1.2 billion
in ebitda
and is he growing via acquisition or is
he just rolling this out and crushing
competition across
the country we're going to talk about
that but what he said was we got there
partly through acquisitions partly
through organic growth developed by
developing greenfield locations
he goes we grew by using the same
strategy at united ways we bought about
two-thirds of the branch locations and
colg started another third
from scratch i actually prefer cold
starts is what he said
the business plan for united rentals was
to become the largest equipment rental
company in the world
and leverage our purchasing power
branding and other advantages of size
within 13 months we became number one
leap-frogging
fleet frogging hertz which had become
the equipment rental which was the
number one equipment rental business in
1965.
another thing we did was we went fast uh
we went public fast we formed
the company on labor day weekend and we
were trading on the new york stock
exchange by
december labor day weekend is in may i
think right
so they started the company in may and
five months is that seven months that
seven months later they were public
merrill lynch said it was the fastest
growing or the fastest ipo they've ever
seen
and i stepped down uh uh and so
he stepped down of united rentals in
2007 this is only
five years after starting and
to start the next company but when he
stepped down united rentals if you look
it up now
i believe their market cap is 25 billion
dollars
so he spent five years on this company
and it's worth 25 billion dollars
crazy so listen to what he did after
this
after i stepped down i began looking for
my next big thing
i studied tons of industries and i ended
up concentrating on transportation
and logistics it's larger and more
fragmented than the industries i've been
i've previously been involved in it's a
13 billion dollar
um sorry a 13 trillion dollar
industry and here's what this guy says
this guy at the time
is already multi-billionaire but let me
see if i um
i have he wrote out what he does which
was basically
he basically spends three months he
reads tons of reports and then he calls
a hundred experts in each industry and
he just goes and he sits down with them
and he just asks them questions it might
as well be a podcast all
that's like exactly how he learned so
he's this multi-billionaire he's his big
shot he's done all this amazing stuff
and he calls these people and he just
sits down and he listens that's all he
does
it's pretty amazing and he did this and
then he's
in this with his new thing it's called
xpo logist
logistics have you heard of this i have
i have heard of this i think it's a
delivery and logistics company like a
competitor to fedex at least that's my
understanding
well we'll put this in the show notes
but in that document up top
that is the document from where he was
raising money for xpo logistics and then
playing
it looks like it's like supply chain so
it's like getting people things they
need that are critical
on time well in there he um
in that document that i sent you he i
didn't i i couldn't study the whole
thing but in plain english he explains
kind of what they did
and his reasoning for getting into it
and he just says
well i just studied loads of industries
this one seemed industry
interesting i went and um
interviewed a hundred people who are
experts on it i hired really good people
and
we're gonna do x y and z and that x y
and z is exactly what he's done
in his uh last
businesses and now i want to wrap up by
by giving you guys incredibly detailed
um
stats or uh incredibly detailed strategy
on what he
does so his first thing that he does he
looks for huge industries with lots of
fragmentation that are small
and profitable but don't have the
capital to uh to scale
so here's what he says he was in a
nutshell this is how you ramp up a
business
you buy a brokerage or some type of
small business with 30 million dollars
in revenue
and you add 30 to 40 bodies to it and
you double revenue
in time i've looked into companies that
have executed this plan
but most of them don't have the capital
to sustain it i try to find those
businesses and i bring all the capital
to do it
the second thing that he does is he
hires sales people so he says
i like to hire hungry talented
salespeople at a low base
but big upside for incentives i fund
their training for a few months and it's
not that hard for the winners to build a
million dollar book after a year or so
um it's a business where you have to
make 99 calls a day
and do one or two deals so you have to
hire people who are
psycho i actually don't know this word
what's this we have supplier people who
are psycho chromatically test high on
the need to win
scale and low on the need to be liked
scale a sales person will have a base of
25 000 or 35 000
but can make many times that amount
through an incentivize a really good
incentive program
once you get the right people in the
system and integrate them on the right
i.t
it can be really powerful and finally
speaking of i.t
when someone asked him what was the best
acquisition of all time they ever made
he said they made a powerful software
acquisition
with a politically incorrect name called
rental man
and we used that to integrate all of our
rental businesses we rolled up into that
company
we couldn't have made the hundreds of
acquisitions we did without
rental man and that was his best
acquisition of all time
and that my friend is brad
jacobs and i can go on i
i like i both love and and um find these
guys kind of mysterious and i kind of
wonder like
what the thing that's missing in all
this is like what keeps him going
what's his purpose how do you how does
he use his money
and and like why does he do this right
what's the driving force
i researched him and the guy looks like
a
wall street stiff did you look up what
he looks like yeah he looks kind of like
um
there's like a character actor that he
looks like i'll try and find a photo of
him
like a generic nerdy like steve ballmer
looking kind of guy
yeah he looks like he would be like in
biden or trump's cabinet
uh yeah yeah but i've actually seen
interviews with him he's very endearing
and
i think that he's not actually just a
stiff
like wall street like just milk all the
numbers out
i actually think that he um just this is
his bill this is his urge he just loves
to build
and and and he constantly talks about
integrity he goes the common denominator
of everything we buy is the people who
we buy from have to have high integrity
and also one of our moats is we take
care of the people
of the businesses who work for the
businesses that we're inheriting
in fact the biggest risk of our plan is
that the people who
we buy companies from they leave and so
we treat them all
really really well and so i don't think
this is actually [__]
because when i got his energy from
interviews i actually believed that he
was a good dude and this was just his
art
what do you think though what do you
think he does with his money is that
kind of public does he do any
philanthropy or
or anything because i always find it so
interesting i mean there's two ways to
look at like
doing good in the world it's like okay
you do capitalism right you employ a
whole bunch of people you make an
industry more efficient
you add to global gdp you know good
things happen
because he does this right but on the
flip side like what's driving
making more money and maybe it is just
continually maniacally going industry by
industry and improving them and
optimizing them
that's his like gift or whatever but um
but the guy i'm going to talk about next
is really interesting because
he basically uses all his money to do
crazy good things right which is really
fascinating i'll talk about him in a
minute
but do you have any sense of what this
guy does like no with his money like
doesn't he like he's very much
like i don't i cannot figure it out but
i will
i can wrap this up by saying there's a
few things that i've learned from this
person
the first is like taking the red pill
which is like
have you heard i i don't know someone
just used that phrase to me their day
and
and i'm picking it up you should be
careful it's uh associated with all
sorts of
not so uh not so positive connotations
oh well i didn't know that what i mean
is like i guess his
perspective like when you look at what
this person is capable of doing
you think or when you read what he's
done if you didn't know it was true you
would say well that's impossible no one
can do that
but the person has done it repeatedly
over and over and over again
and he seems pretty nonchalant about
that and so my
what i'm learning from him is that um
you can create these amazing things
and it's hard but maybe could be kind of
simple
well it's so inspiring right you
basically go find an industry that has
let's look at the restaurant and
industry in general right restaurants
are disorganized they're very difficult
businesses they're very
low margin people have done this
essentially in restaurants by building
fast food chains right so you go in you
build systems you do training you
incentivize people the right way
and you can make a lot of money doing
that but you can't make a lot of money
usually in an individual restaurant so
what he's done is he's gone out and fun
he finds these fragmented disorganized
industries like you know waste
management or logistics
and he goes okay i'm gonna do the fast
food chain
uh except for that industry it's yeah
and
and it's really really cool um the
second thing that that i learned is he
actually does the same thing as you well
i actually don't know your numbers but i
bet you
they're similar he likes to buy
companies between five and ten times
earnings
um and that's like his number um that's
what i mean
yeah i'd say i love to buy businesses
for that um
that valuation or whatever um but the
problem the problem with buying a
business at that valuation is like
you're buying kind of a crappy business
often if it's going to be that low
well these are trash what he's doing
yeah exactly what he's doing is kind of
building a platform where he's like i
just need one
so i can build the systems and then i
can go and acquire a whole bunch more
and the final thing and then we can move
on is
the guy loves debt and often times that
ends bad
but i personally have zero debt in my
life and i've never really had debt
and i actually think though that not
having debt or not having some type of
leverage
is silly and i've read articles about
him and he talks about it very
unemotionally like he seems like a
really charismatic emotional guy
but he's like yeah look like this makes
total sense because i can grow this
business at 30 percent uh
therefore the cost if i look at the cost
of capital i should allocate capital
this and it just makes sense and i hear
that i'm like
yeah everything you're saying makes
total sense i'm just so fearful and it's
really cool that you don't seem to have
that fear
and i think that's interesting yeah and
i think debt
that's it goes back to like not having
fatal potential potential blow ups in
your life right so
i've heard everything from like you know
i was talking to a guy and he was saying
i'm
super rich guy and he goes i've paid off
my house in full
i never have a mortgage or whatever and
it just gives him that sense of security
maybe this guy has he's so rich he's
already made a whole bunch of money on
other stuff that
he can take a little more risk or he
knows how to structure dead or whatever
it is
um you hear both things and the problem
is you only hear the stories about the
guys who levered up and did really well
there may be a whole bunch of other brad
jacob types
who went out levered up and it totally
[__] them they hit a speed bump oh
yeah lost all that money
so the interesting thing about this
though um
the and the difference between what we
do in this guy is this guy's essentially
starting a new business
um and what we like to do is find a
business that's already working
where we can actually just leave it and
make it you know maybe we'll help
plug in a new ceo or something like that
but we're actually not messing with it
we're not changing the dna this guy's
like
modifying the dna he's doing like crispr
on these businesses
he's working and working with them and
turning that he's working really hard
right so
i don't like to work hard i get really
excited when i hear about people like
this
i'm so glad they exist but i'm like oh
my god this is a big lift
i don't want to do it's a big lift but
it does seem cool
it's cool uh it's this is like cornrows
or sleeve tattoos i think they're cool i
just don't want it
they're cool for certain people and it
works great for them exactly
face tattoos not
it's pretty sick that someone else has
it but i don't know if i want it
totally totally um and i i i think again
going back to like
this guy does make the world better
because he employs a lot of people in
industries where
you know people aren't getting laid off
because of this guy
right because he's managed this business
better he can probably pay people better
give them more opportunity
um he's not going to lay them off
because he's got this global business
so it's very it's very positive but what
i would want to understand is what's the
guy do with the money
what's driving him like is he like a sad
empty hole where he's like i have to
keep doing this
all the time or is he like you know
donating it all to charity
or views this as super philanthropic in
and of itself i'm super curious about
that
um i don't know
i i like the only thing that i saw is
that he has a good glass door rating
um which i actually everyone dismisses
glassdoor
but i'm like yeah it there is like i got
made fun of from the michael saylor
podcast i brought that up i'm like yeah
it's not like
facts but it's like there's a signal
that you can learn a little bit
it's the glass door people only go on
glassdoor when they really hate you
so it's like the voices of the people
who hate you most and if the people who
hate you most
are saying good things or at least okay
things that's a really good sign
right so anyway it's interesting but
let's move on to your guy
because i actually know who this guy is
or i know of him
um so yeah my guy is
um dan gilbert um and the reason i
thought he was super interesting i've
talked about him a little bit in the
past but
this guy has had a freaking massive year
so uh you know two years ago or
something
he was worth like six seven eight
billion dollars
uh baby billionaire now he's worth 57
billion
wait five seven five seven 57 he's
number 21 one of the wealthiest people
in the united states
um and this is he's had a crazy couple
years so
i think it was about two years ago he
had a massive stroke
so he was on the golf course with a
friend and
the doc the friend just happened to be a
doctor and he said oh that's weird i'm
having these symptoms
so his doctor got him to the hospital
and
they he had a stroke in the hospital
and in the hospital they were able to do
this special procedure that if he hadn't
been in the hospital he might have died
or it might have been way worse right
so he got super lucky yeah and you know
as lucky as one can be having a stroke
horrible thing
and uh now he's been basically
rehabilitating himself and getting back
on his feet for last two years
and so he's had this horrible personal
tragedy but at the same time he's become
worth you know 6x
uh you know as much and i bet he would
give it all away to not have had the
stroke or
whatever so it's super fascinating um
this guy
uh he described it really well when they
ipo they just ipo'd his mortgage
business
he said this is a 30 year or sorry an
overnight success 30 years
in the making um so this guy's been at
it for a really long time
um i think he's super interesting
because he started with nothing
um his dad owned a struggling detroit
bar
he worked in pizza delivery he just kind
of stumbled into hustling
and was a good sales person and he
started a business
and that business was a company called
uh rock financial which became quicken
loans which i'll talk about in a second
one of the reasons i think he's really
interested interesting is that he's
invested into revitalizing his home city
so his mission is to revitalize detroit
and get it back on its feet because it's
struggled a lot
um he's like a capitalist batman in
detroit
and i'll talk about some of the cool
stuff he's done and one of the things i
like about him as well is that he
uh he uh does a lot of stuff that might
not work
he takes big swings takes big risks that
he think can make the world better
and he invests in all sorts of crazy
ideas uh he also has five kids
which i think is pretty freaking cool i
love to see that
he's you know billionaires they're not
just like miserable by themselves and
they care about kids and stuff
and seems pretty family focused um and
then you know he's been through these
personal challenges this stroke
and then also his eldest son was born
with this disease called
neurofibromatosis which is like super
rare
and he's poured a bunch of money uh his
own money into funding
research around that disease so it's
been fascinating
um so he said uh there's a quote he said
when i when we grew up
all i wanted to do uh was do two things
own a sports team
and a casino and now he owns both uh so
this is kind of like a childhood dream
and his companies are quicken loans
which is the largest home mortgage
lender in the united states they're
bigger than wells fargo which is
freaking crazy
uh he owns the cleveland cavaliers the
basketball team and a few other sports
franchises
until recently he owned a casino i think
it was called jack
which owned a whole bunch of casinos but
i think he sold it and then he also owns
rock ventures and rock ventures is where
all the big swings happen and all the
philanthropic stuff happens so
they own a ton of real estate almost all
in detroit
and then they do venture capital and
they've invested in
everything from uh restaurants to
you know real estate businesses hotels
crazy tech companies and all sorts of
other stuff he owns
rob report which is like walmart can i
tell you a few more things that he owns
that's interesting
um so he owns i think he owns fat head
do you know fat head yeah yeah i believe
sports
it's like those like big hands and stuff
and like yeah yeah weird
if you're a kid and you want to put like
a like the face of michael jordan on
your wall
it's like a decal that you put on your
wall i think he owns the whole thing
he just bought dictionary.com and
thesaurus.com
um totally random we were actually we
helped him i know him i'll talk about
that a little bit but uh we helped him
with that acquisition a little bit
oh no way so you know about it it was
like a it's like a 20 million dollar
revenue thing or more maybe um
it's been doing that for like 10 years i
i mean i don't have any
insider information these are guesses um
and am i right yeah yeah he owns
dictionary.com and thesaurus.com
um and like when you talk to him about
why he bought it he's just like
you know i think this is cool like he's
just like i had all these ideas of
things i could do with it
he's not like going oh i bought it for x
times ebitda and i'm gonna make a 20
return and this is what i find so cool
about this guy is he'll just say yes
so he owns like rob report which is like
a magazine for rich people
dictionary.com um he owns shi or has a
very large stake in shinola
so shinola has this like insane hotel in
detroit
they make watches uh he owns uh stockx
which is like a
it's basically like a stock market for
sneakers and watches
which is awesome on that because like he
co-founded
like his si hell is he in the 70s yet
he's like 50
50 something 56 i think he's that young
wow okay
that's a little bit older than like a
sneaker head
uh and he totally i he's a co-founder i
know that so he was it he sports
he's got investments in esports like
just all sorts of stuff and then he's
also
a large lp and a lot of venture funds
kind of quietly like he's the largest lp
in ludlow ventures he's got his own
venture fund
and so you look at it and he's got this
barbell right he's got
a really kind of dull boring you know
mortgage business which is really
innovative in and of itself just what
he's done is kind of like brad
what he's done is like basically taking
this fragmented
crappy industry run by banks and small
lenders and like
built out this massive structure and
been very innovative around culture
and other stuff um so let me let me just
give the history of what happened though
so basically in 1985 him and his little
brother
uh start rock financial which is
basically
a independent mortgage lender so when
someone
you know needs a house or whatever it is
they go to them they
figure out they basically make them an
offer to lend them the money
and then i think they go sell the risk
so they would lend them the money
and then they would sell it off to a
bank over time um
and basically in the late 1990s company
grew into a huge
business one of the largest uh
independent in the united states
and with the dot-com boom they launched
an internet strategy
where they just made uh rock financial i
think it was rockfinancial.com or
digitalmortgage.com or something like
that
and in uh and
in 2000 what was it no 1997 or something
intuit acquired their business because
they were like oh my god this is like
you know this huge disruptive
digital finance thing and so um what
ended up happening is the dot-com boom
blew up
and in 2002 he came back and he bought
his business back so he sold it for a
ton of money
into it her sale was 90 million
okay is that right he basically i i
don't know i don't have the exact number
here
but um something like that so you know
the guy made a lot of money
especially for the 90s but he wasn't
like a crazy billionaire yet
then he raised money from investors so
himself
and some friends went back to intuit
bought it back
i don't know what the number was and
what's interesting is they kept the
quicken loans name
so intuit owns quicken the financial
personal finance software
and they branded it quicken and so now
there's this weird other business they
own
called quicken loans even though that's
an intuit brand so it's kind of a funny
uh thing and it just kept hibiscu took
it
took it back got rid of all the crap
into it that added
and started growing at a again and
this whole time he's living in detroit
and watching his own city
totally fall apart so in the financial
crisis
uh you know detroit i think went
bankrupt and
he meanwhile is like super rich and
living out in the suburbs
and he says [__] it we're moving back
into detroit and he moves his entire
team
uh into detroit so he had 4 000 or so
employees they literally bought if you
actually go to detroit there's this
um it's called campus martius or
something and it's right in the center
of downtown this huge building
um and he moved everyone there and he
basically said
for my own employees and for the city
we're just gonna fix it
and so he built uh casinos he built like
a private security
uh firm so if you walk around there's
like there's like normal police and then
there's like dan's police
um he bought billions of dollars of
derelict buildings
uh you know literally like you go there
and there's like skyscrapers
and he's just it's like going to chicago
and he's like oh yeah i own the sears
tower
and this and this and like basically all
of downtown detroit he owns like 20 30
percent of
and um he also just announced that he's
gonna pay off 300 million dollars of
property taxes
for detroit residences so this guy
really really cares
about detroit and since since he started
it
it's now become the largest uh
independent mortgage business in in the
united states
uh you know they've gone public they had
this huge ipo
and it's been it's been a crazy story
what i love about this guy is just he's
got such a crazy collection of
businesses
i think if i remember correctly i think
i'm probably i think i'm right
but i believe he sold it for 90. he
bought it back for like
20. and i think he took it public did he
take it public like
either recently or right away quite
recently like it was like
like uh six months ago and he owned most
of it when it went public he owned like
85 or 90 percent of it
and it went it's totally crazy what's
the market cap now
the market cap is let's see here market
caps 46 billion dollars
wow so yeah where's the other 10 billion
come from just his other stu just as
others he owns a lot yeah a lot of real
estate you think the cavaliers are
probably worth you know 500 million to
it
we forgot about that whole part here
you know all these stockx is worth i
think a couple billion dollars now
um so he's just got this crazy
collection of stuff
and and so chris and i got to meet him
um
the other cool thing about this guy is
like he's just a wild card
like i so i read about him in the new
york times they did this profile of him
and i i have this habit of just cold
emailing people i think are interesting
and like 95
of the time i just don't hear back but i
wrote him an email
at like one in the morning and said hey
you you know i'd love to meet you
and i get an email back like five
minutes later and he's just like
yeah sure and then i got a follow-up
from his assistant
and we ended up flying to detroit and it
you know sometimes when you go and meet
these billionaires they're like
whatever you know you walk in you get 20
minutes with them
that's that he was like incredible they
like planned this whole
tour of detroit it was like this two-day
thing like
ev they set us up in their hotel um
and then dan spent like two hours with
us and he's just this super
nice guy he's like deeply interested in
what we're doing
um and super engaged and like every
business i mentioned to him
he'd be like how does that work how can
we get involved what can we do
how can we do it like he wants to say
yes to ideas which i always find really
inspiring right because i think some of
these people have gotten really rich
they've gotten rich by being like
hyper disciplined and just saying no to
everything but he says yes before no
that's really interesting that's what
shawn acts like and i usually i usually
say no to everything sean says yes to
everything and my joke is that like
i'm like my success is probably going to
be quite predictable
and it will be really good sean's
success is he's gonna
go completely broke and die like young
or
he's gonna become a billionaire super
fat like you know it's like a
it's a high risk high reward type of
thing and that's not the reality but
that's my joke but
um and you actually can you tell the
story of how you met someone recently
who's a big deal and they said like oh
just call whenever like i'm free all day
yeah uh so i recently got
um
yeah well i got i was pretty crazy i got
a chance to talk to warren buffett on
the phone
um some some guy i was talking to i was
saying you know i'm trying to figure out
philanthropy and how to give money away
and literally he goes oh you should talk
to warren buffett
and i was like what do you mean and then
he just like cc intro'd me to warren
buffett right it was
one of the weirdest things that's ever
happened to me and it was amazing and i
was like kind of nervous like warren
buffett's like my hero
uh you know i i was never not expecting
this it was just like a random friday
and warren buffett's secretary emails me
back and just says oh yeah
you know call call him whenever you know
he'll he'll pick up
and so i call and they get i could put
right through
and it's just warren freaking buffett on
the phone and basically he said you know
oh yeah
i'm not doing anything i can talk for as
long as you want and i just got to pick
his brain
for an hour uh and it was insanely
inspiring right like this guy
he was exactly who you'd expect him to
be i find with a lot of these guys it's
like don't meet your heroes
and uh they're not who they appear to be
on tv all day
he's available all day he talked to me
for an hour and a half
and he was just the nicest guy he's
exactly like he was on his
cnbc interviews showed a ton of interest
in what i was doing and like i literally
just like
grilled him for like 30 minutes
yeah he's definitely on a landline and
it was just it's always it's always
really nice when someone
is what you hoped they'd be that's great
so we'll bring it back to gilbert but
just so you know i have a feeling the
clip that you just said about buffett
that's gonna go viral um uh
so hopefully you're okay with that uh
and if you're not
you could tell us um all right um
you you have something here about his
strategy and his culture because i
actually wanna know what motivates this
guy
and do you think that he was
so i actually sent this to you i think i
use newspapers.newspaper.com and i
actually like to read all articles and i
read a ton of old articles about rock
financial and
even before it got bought by quicken dan
was like a detroit guy it seemed like it
was like he was very um
confident not arrogant but he was like
he just had the it factor at a young age
it seems like and um then i read his uh
what's it called the 10k or s1 when they
go public and uh he was like
30 and everyone on his company was like
in their 40s so it was like he was like
a young guy
and the business was booming and very
interesting very seemed like a very
confident person at a young age what do
you think motivated i think he's been
super rich for a long time
well yeah i was going to say like he
says there's a great quote he says
one of our things is that money follows
it does not lead
so we want people that are fired up and
passionate about their mission
and people that aren't so married to
spreadsheets and thinking
that kind that kind of voodoo controls
the future because it doesn't so
this theme of doing things because it's
cool or because it makes sense or
because you're driven to do it
versus based on financial analysis and
that's the feeling i get about this guy
is like
he says yes and he wings it
and he takes risks and he takes big bets
and i think it goes back to this thing
of
what's the point of making a bunch of
money if you're not going to try and do
cool stuff with it
and so he's just very very inspiring in
that way
and one of the ways that he wins is that
he focuses massively on culture
so when we visited him uh you know he
probably had
five or six thousand employees at the
time and he said i still
personally on board every single
employee so once a month
i go into like a conference center and
there's a you know 100 or 200 new
employees coming in
and i will spend all day with them
talking to them about our culture
and what you know what we represent and
he gave me this book
and he calls it isms these are the like
the ideals that they live by or whatever
and usually you get these stupid
corporate
bse things like you know we value
integrity or whatever
but it's this series of um of kind of
like words to live by
so you know some of them yes before
no money doesn't follow it leads
we'll figure it out every second counts
yeah
a penny saved is a penny you know don't
obsess over saving just do the right
thing
uh anyway i i just love how he does that
and then i also love again this barbell
strategy uh where he's got a
conservative cash flowing business
and that funds crazy [__] and big bets
and interesting stuff
um and you know he also said anyone who
dies with money in the bank is a failure
right so this is not a guy who's going
to go hoard it or whatever he's going to
give it all back to society which i
think is super cool
that's great do you think does he have
um
so none of this would have been possible
without quicken working out yeah
was he has he was he always hands on or
did he delegate right away you think
well he's got this really smart ceo
called jay farner
and jay my understanding is jay now runs
that business
and dan floats above doing all of his
different stuff
but i don't know i think jay's been
there for a really long time
so i'm not sure but i think he was the
he's the chairman
or something i think he's kind of taken
that role where he starts up the
business he's super involved he's still
on but he he kind of lets someone else
operate it day-to-day
damn this is awesome i i've heard him
talk my
and i judged him incorrectly i think
because he's a
nice dresser and he's kind of good
looking i and he like slicks
like literally slicks his hair back i
thought that he was frankly kind of a
douche
um and i heard him talk a couple times
and i'm like oh wait this guy
is not how i thought he was going to be
super humble yeah he
he talks like with the michigan accent
he
is super down-to-earth super funny like
we when we were meeting him we're like
god this guy's like he owns casinos he's
got slicked back hair
he almost dresses like a gangster or
something he's got like kind of a
serious
yeah you look and you know there's a
story about him like punching a guy in
the face at a party like
you're kind of like who is this guy but
when you meet him
he's just completely real and down to
earth and cool and
and i would say one we've met lots of
very successful people
and i'd say he's one of the only ones
that i would go
you know there's a small list of people
where i'd go i'd really want to be like
this guy
right i'd love to trade lives with him
is he grinding still or does he relax a
little
well i don't know i mean i think with
the stroke there's a question of you
know did he have the stroke because he
was stressed or
you know high blood pressure i i don't
know um
but i'm not sure i i don't know what his
uh approach to work is or whatever i
haven't worked super deeply with him i
mean we looked at that dictionary.com
thing for him
gave him our feedback on what we would
do with it um
and we've we've done like you know meta
lab worked with with quicken loans a
little bit
and dan's lit me up before via text
saying you know this design sucks and
you need to make it better
but again like that's what's cool about
him is like he's running this
freaking 60 billion dollar empire and
yet he's still texting me
going hey this website sucks and that
color's wrong and
you know tweak this um he's just he's a
real person
right and so many of these guys they're
like reptilian
right these bill they're they're too
slick
they they're never you know never out of
place they won't admit
any of their flaws and you know it's
neat when you meet people and they're
just real
they're flawed human beings uh they're
doing cool stuff
that's great i've i've just become a dan
gilbert fan i
i prepared more than you i think and i
think you you
picked the right guy and you won i think
i think you've won uh i've become
uh you've convinced me to become a um
a gilbert fan a dan gilbert fan he um he
also uh
is really into hip-hop culture so like
he did um
i think he's the biggest investor in rap
genius which is not really relevant
anymore but better for worse
yeah for better for worse correct but
it's
whatever i mean you're gonna lose
sometimes if you say yes to everything
but that's cool that he said yes to that
and he's in uh
so he's kind of got like street cred and
he does actually seem like a pretty cool
guy
um um and then that dictionary.com deal
i according to the news it said that he
bought it for a hundred million
which is pretty sick i bet you that
company could do
10 or 15 million a year in profit if it
wanted to
um but you would know more than i do but
that's pretty sick i'm a dan gilbert fan
now
yeah me too um abreu
what do you think of our first episode
of billy's
billy's but billy of the week i liked it
i think there's a lot to take away from
both those guys
i'm curious to see what people's
reactions are going to be but i think
this could become
a weekly thing sick
um i think we're scheduled to do it for
at least one more week right andrew
are we doing we're gonna do the same
format next time you want to do a
different one
well i like well i like doing this but
the research is annoying it's so much
fun when i can just wing it
i have something cool for you so okay
at hubspot we now have two full-time
researchers
so if you'd like we can send a couple
people
to them i mean i didn't do it this time
but abray you can uh we'll hook it up
you mention a few people who you're
interested in and our researchers will
take care of it
oh dude i love that that's awesome so uh
if you're looking for
mr mr corporate big shot i know
it's trust me it's also where's your
crazy camera set up are you on your like
crazy dslr right now
no but have you you've seen it right
it's real nice right yeah it looks
amazing
i um i'm driving to st louis to meet a
newborn
baby uh my my niece but i am stopping in
oklahoma city
to meet up with a bunch of listeners
because that was like the middle ground
and so i just tweeted out i'll be in
oklahoma city and like 50 people signed
up so i decided to stop and stay and
meet people
and then i'm going to drive to st louis
tomorrow isn't it isn't it crazy when
you think about i remember doing this
with our um
we had this invoicing software like 10
years ago or whatever
and uh it was really small but we had
thousands of customers
and you don't realize like for you
you're just doing a podcast
and you see these numbers it's like oh
yeah like we got 20 000 listeners or
whatever
when you actually think like okay
there's actually 20 000 people all over
the world
listening to you who feel like they know
you and when you tweet out that hey i'm
in oklahoma city some random city in the
united states and
50 people show up in person that's
freaking cool
it was even more yeah i was shocked more
people tried to rsvp and then i tweeted
that i was in
or i was going here and then someone was
like hey i own this fancy hotel would
you like to stay here i go yup you guys
have a restaurant he goes yep i go all
right i'm gonna have 50 people come
and we just created an event by page and
it's sold out right i mean wait are you
vaccinated
yeah oh dude it's taking forever in
canada it's gonna be like another two
months
yeah i'm vaccinated and uh i still wear
the mask to make people comfortable but
uh
i'm vaccinated so i'm just going to
i don't know i i i don't even know
you got two dose or one dose two hmm
which one's the problem yeah yeah it was
one of those
uh i'm so jealous i'm so i'm so done me
and my wife
got it done um and uh
so that's why i'm i'm i'm traveling a
little bit do you think that this will
be
like you're gonna be happier as a result
of this like you this [__] it's kind of
like
you had a hundred days of rain and then
all of a sudden it's sunny and you
appreciate it way more than if you lived
in southern california like
did you just have like a boring year and
now it's super exciting
does it feel like you've just been
letter to prison or something
from a personal perspective from a
business perspective from
fitness from bot from like my bodies and
i don't want to sound callous because i
know there's bad stuff covid was
so good to me i i loved i mean
i kicked ass my family night we we
crushed it i enjoyed
the down time i enjoyed getting fit i
enjoyed moving
business-wise business boomed um are you
in the same boat
no i would say um if anything like i
have a tendency to be a workaholic
and so what i used to do is
i would go work at a cafe and then i'd
run into my buddies who would also go to
the same cafe or someone i knew would
come
and i'd have lunch with them or i'd go
for a walk and it would just force me to
kind of get away from work and have more
perspective and break up my day
or i'd be still working but i'd be going
from meeting to meeting the meeting and
getting eye contact and face time
and now um all i do is work right
like i'm just it's basically i'm at a
i'm at a house like i work out of a
house
that we rent and then i drive home and
that's it and it's been this winter it's
been too cold up here in canada
to really go and sit on a patio and so
it's
a total bummer and i'm like an extreme
extrovert like i love
spending like two three hours with other
people every day
so it's been it's been grinding on me
for sure why don't you come down to
texas
because well so my wife and i've been
building a house for the last three
years
we're moving into the new house at the
end of this month and
otherwise i've been i've gone to my wife
but like we just need to move to hawaii
for six months
and just f off go get vaccinated and
then wait for the border to reopen
the reason i can't fly to texas is if i
fly over the border
when you come back to canada there's a
mandatory two-week government quarantine
even if you're vaccinated
so it means with two kids i gotta be
stuck in the house or by myself
my kids can't go to school it's just
like that's not fun
do you the the downside that i've had is
so many
i've met people digitally and i hate
that i
have so many online friends and so my
phone texts are always
my i get so many and it's not like
because i'm necessarily popular but
uh i get so many text messages i get so
many emails
uh i do phone calls all the time and so
my
problem is i don't want people to
contact me anymore or i just ignore them
um and so it goes back to like this
problem that you'd be so stoked to have
like
five years ago like i have the same
problem of like i post on twitter
and then someone dm's me hey check out
my business
and would you get on the phone with me
and talk about it and five years ago it
would have been like stoked i'm like oh
my god i can
help all these entrepreneurs and make
all these new friends and now it's like
i get 20 of those a day
and i just want everyone to leave me
alone and like i'm trying to figure out
how to
even just deal with the amount of email
and text i'm getting
and this is this is the downside with
scale right like with 35 businesses
there's always something happening
there's always a problem to solve or
some a text to respond to or an email
and so it's uh pros and cons right i
always
make this kind of i historically i
always kind of claim to be this guy
where i'm like
oh i have this great life i have all
this freedom i don't run my businesses
but that worked when we were 20
companies two years ago
now i'm hitting this threshold where i'm
like okay i'm back to being busy again
how do i restructure this yeah you're
gonna you're gonna have to hire a
you did if one you've got to hire
someone to run that i need a chief of
staff
i hate that title i know i find that so
douchey
no you need a ceo of tanya now maybe
yeah um
i always love i always love these like
silicon valley ceos who are hiring an
assistant they're like i need a chief of
staff like i'm the president
that's so ridiculous yeah they should
just replace themselves um
and then the second thing that you did
which
might hurt you but you'll figure your
way out is you painted the picture of
yourself as this guy who's like
what are you guys talking about like so
easy why you work so hard
like and now that you're doing it
everyone's gonna be like
told you told you well i think the way i
describe it is
when you okay so when you look at other
people's businesses and you've
hired uh executives or you've let's say
let's say you own a bakery right and
there's
there's you're looking at a bakery owner
and they're [__] staying up until two
in the morning baking they're sleeping
for four hours they're working the till
they're covered in flour and you're
looking at them and going dude it's so
easy
just go hire a staff and build a manual
right like this is not rocket science
and then you do that and now you're the
ceo of the bakery
and now you got to deal with people
problems in a different level of of
issues
and to me it's like i've done the right
stuff and i've hired great ceos i have
all that
it's just now there's like too many
different things to keep tabs on in my
brain
and i think humans aren't designed for
thinking about more than like two
problems at once no so when i have like
problems or 30 businesses it's just hard
to kind of feel on top of everything
i think i don't know i what i learned i
think i learned this from you actually
and then another person was like i was
like oh i'm just gonna let this burn
and oftentimes it doesn't it
yeah survives or gets usually usually
they figure it out right if you don't
respond to the text
and you take four hours to respond
instead of 10 minutes
usually it's like oh actually i figured
this out or you train people
that you don't respond quickly unless
it's an emergency and they go figure it
out but if you jump in and you solve
their problem all the time
they're just going to keep asking you
yeah and i i kind of came to the
conclusion of like
i'm just going to let it die and then it
goes
it goes back to that thing of like you
know tim ferriss or any of these people
who talk about these hacks the hacks are
real but what's what's
what's also real is human nature is to
be miserable right so like you know you
know old people
who are like rich retired and they're
angry about their neighbors or their
grass
or their vacation got canceled or
whatever the silly thing is
and you're looking at it you're like
dude you have a nice life relax
enjoy yourself i think humans just
always need something to be upset about
and so for me it's like you know i've
got i've got
i'm so happy with where i'm at and i i
love all my businesses but i
managed to still make myself miserable i
would change it too we don't need
something to be unhappy about but we
need a war
i need a fight i there i i agree like it
it's good for me to have a fight i love
uh having an enemy but then i think i'm
a double-edged sword
i'm the same way my business partner
always says you need an enemy
um i i get so fired up with that or like
being wartime ceo
but then like okay yesterday i did this
viral tweet i got the biggest tweet ever
right
how many people did that reach 30 000
likes i haven't checked the number of
people
i think is uh it was like it was like
tens of thousands or something of
retweets right so one of the pieces
so shawn's clubhouse thing reached i
think six million people
but your thing looked like it was even
bigger where do i look does twitter
analytics
yeah on your phone there's this thing
called insights so you go to the tweet
and then underneath the like button
like the heart button you see something
that says view insights
so i got 7.2 million impressions wow
and total engagement of 1 million 1.1
that is
7.2 million is so good
yeah so it's crazy so anyway so i did
that and
you know it was like dopamine hits i was
talking about a failure right it was
like i hadn't really talked about it
i publicly revealed i lost 10 million
dollars on this
business i'd started and it was just
kind of like exercising a demon right
hey i'm just sharing this
[__] horrible story or whatever and
the thing about twitter is that
two to five percent of your audience
will always misinterpret
what you say go you know oh hey
technicality
or this isn't right or you're you're
trying to come across this way and
that's not true or whatever it is it's a
classic
so how privileged of you totally oh how
privileged you lost 10 million dollars
or whatever it is
and and i had it was it was hilarious i
had um
so my the story was basically we started
productivity software called flow
i decided to bootstrap it like base camp
and
we had a big competitor asana and asana
was run by billionaire the co-founder of
facebook
he raised a shitload of money and
originally i was like oh no we've got a
better product
and then they just made their product
better and they outspent us on marketing
and we we got killed right
and so i do this and you know the co-fou
the co-founder of asana
who i really like and i thought i
complimented him in this story
he started taking issue and saying you
know in 20 we didn't even have a
marketing budget in 2012 and all this
stuff
and then was fighting with justin dustin
was like fighting with me on twitter and
i'm like dude i like
you yeah you're like i like you i'm
complimenting you you're like such a
nice guy
and and you said it really nicely and
all this stuff
and so he's in the tweet you said dustin
very nicely said we're gonna crush you
and he did
and um but i love him a lot that's what
you said i didn't really he didn't even
say
i'm gonna crush you it's more like hey
here's all the challenges you guys are
going to have
you should really join us and we'll do
this together right it was this very
collaborative message
because i think they wanted to buy us
but um and then you know my other he
like a hero of mine david heinemeyer
hanson who like i've
worshipped forever in terms of like
their business they've built
um he wrote this whole post about how
i'm pro-venture
and i'm you know mis misallocating you
know success to all this stuff
and he totally twisted what i was saying
and so it's like this downside of
twitter and being public of like
starting a fight and stirring the pot
and sharing what's going on
like your buddy yeah and i'm friends
with him we're texting about it and it's
fine
but it goes back to like the negative
emotions of sharing and being out there
and having
you know having enemies comes with
shitty emotions right
and i'm debating this right now like is
it worth over the last two years like
i love coming on here and stuff but is
it worth having a public profile
right is it is it worth the negative
emotions i think
that that this is like a rich person's
problem it's kind of
not like not en rich of whatever you
want so like whatever you're trying to
get whatever you're trying to achieve
you get it and you're like
uh man that's not as good as i thought
and i've experienced this as as well so
if you've noticed like
online i've actually try to be far more
low-key than ever before because
um i find the pressure and i find the
attention to actually be
a net negative although that's like
[__] it's like that's a shitty thing
to say because it's not really a net
negative because i'm happy with the
outcome and i wouldn't trade it so it's
not really a net negative
but uh i completely agree i think that
right now well this is the question is
could you
be known could you still be outspoken
in audio and stuff but just have your
photo nowhere so no one knows
and not reveal too much personally or
whatever because the the
cool thing as an extrovert i like lit up
when you're like oh dude i
i tweeted this out and 50 cool people
showed up at this event
right like that is the power that's by
by not being public you actually aren't
a you're not sharing your lessons and
you're not helping the next generation
of entrepreneurs and stuff
but you're not connecting with new
people and you're making all these
friends as a result maybe you don't need
new friends
but uh that's so cool yeah so there's we
have two options one
we just have thicker skin and stop being
such a wussy
um about it which like is hard it's
really hard
um or we build anonymously a little bit
more
and we're actually having what's this
the guy's name biology
the uh cryptocurrency yeah he's going to
be on the podcast in a couple weeks i
think right abreu
and um he uh his whole he's got this big
prediction that
um that's going to be the norm is that
your co-workers are actually going to be
anonymous
and i want to i wanted to talk about
that because i
kind of agreed i think there's a world
where that could happen
it's fascinating to think about like if
you think about like if you had a work
persona and you're just like
you know sam x and then your sam pardon
your personal life and sam
x has a reputation and you talk about
what you're doing and stuff
that's super i mean there's that guy the
samurai whatever the [__] the guy is
i'm a big fan financial samurai you like
that guy no one knows who he is
right or what's the guy's name mr money
mustache nobody knew who he was
until that new york times profile right
that's the ultimate
totally and and you and i both probably
you you and i were this and
you probably have a lot more we have
friends who we feel like they're
incredibly close friends
and you've not only never met them in
real life you've actually never heard
their voice or
seen their face i've had a ton of
friends like that
uh who i only communicate with and i
know what their profile picture is
um and i consider them to be great
friends um but even
even liquid jack smith right it's like
his username is jack smith but
his photo is just some random cartoon
thing and it's
it's fake and that is smart right like
dude there's
i was texting with someone last night
and he was saying there's a twitter user
i think he has like 200 000 followers or
whatever the guy gets death threats
right and i look at his twitter and i'm
like this isn't like this is pretty
innocuous
he's not like some a controver i can't
say but not super controversial or
anything like that
and the guy gets death threats and you
just go like wow like if that's what
you're dealing with
like i remember i had this guy six years
ago
um a schizophrenic guy in my city
thought
that because we worked with apple we had
the apple watch
before the apple watch came out he
thought we had the apple watch plans and
he showed up in our office
in like a super manic state quivering
and like demanding with his like fist
spared
that we give him the apple watch stuff
right
and we're able to cool him down and get
him out or whatever i have like some
schizophrenic
uh people in my family who knew how to
deal with it but you think about like
that's only going to happen more as you
have a bigger and bigger presence
and that kind of stuff's a little freaky
right you don't want to get like john
lennon
i i call it love knifed you know they
love you so much they're going to stab
you
um really and it is fearful uh
i mean i've not had death threats but
like there's been times where sarah and
i have been on vacation and we'll take
the picture of
take a picture of our guesthou or the
vacation home and we'll um
cover the address but still but i'll get
like five or ten packages
um from people saying like oh we just
found the house on street view
and they'll like send away they'll send
stuff yeah it happens
all the time so i'm not uh that's creepy
they asked me not to take pictures of
the of the house
even if we cover the address
dude that's super creepy and i'm a
nobody you guys you and sean have
two x as many followers i mean and so
yeah it's weird it's so it's so
interesting
that's so it's it's it's a it's such a
first world problem right
oh no i've got this big audience all
these people listen to me or whatever
but
but uh yeah double edged sword yeah you
know people always say that's a good
problem to have that's a first world
problem
and my reply is like yeah you're right
it's still a [__] problem though
totally it's very real and you know i
was saying i was on the phone with
someone
uh the other day and you know he
he was saying um oh yeah you know i want
to be a billionaire
and i was going well think about being a
billionaire you know think about the
pressure of
having billions of dollars and knowing
like you can okay so like here's an
example it's like i read
bill gates new book about climate change
right and i'm going
oh it's okay i don't have enough money
to really do anything in this right i
don't feel any personal responsibility
let's let the crazy billionaire bill
gates or whatever deal with this
and if i was a billionaire i'd be going
oh [__] you know i need to like call
bill and i need to help and i
this is my problem now and if there's a
shooting uh
you know in town in town i need to fund
the police to make it better to solve
these problems like there's a lot of
pressure that comes along with large
amounts of money
and so it's it's interesting to think
about who's what's the right amount of
money
right and i i the people i admire the
most are often the people who have
you know enough money in the bank that
they can do whatever they want
but not so much money that they can turn
into wackos or stress themselves out
what's that threshold of they can do
whatever they want like what does that
mean
i think really it's like five in my city
it's like maybe like five
to twenty million bucks is enough to
you know that's live a great great great
life right you could
obviously do a lot less but i could i
can pretty confidently say that i think
20 is the threshold that you could live
a great life in pretty much any city for
the rest of your life
with 20 yeah i think i would say that
now i mean that's like you could get
like a
crazy apartment in new york live like a
king
and you're you're good forever forever
right but i mean in
with like two million dollars even three
million dollars you can live
somewhere in the world like amazingly
well yeah well um
andrew thank you we'll do it again next
week and we'll um get our research to do
stuff i brought you what do you give
this out of 10
9 out of 10. oh i'll take that that's
good i would not have expected that
you